Let me just remind you the reason why I love
this lecture is that there is a series of common
mistakes that first time an even experienced
entrepreneurs make in thinking about revenue
and pricing. And the first one is that this whole
idea about revenue stream, Steve, I get it. You
know, revenue stream. It’s about the price, the
dollar amount I am charring customers.
That’s a mistake.
And you will see later that pricing is a tactic.
Or maybe I kind of get it, okay, now I understand
that pricing is a tactic, but I’ll set the price
of a product based on how much it costs me
to make it. Well, how else would you set pricing.
It cost me 99 cents to make it. I’ll charge
a $1.25 and, you know, that’s kind of a reasonable
price. We’ll also see why that might be a huge
mistake and leaving lots of money on the table.
And then kind of the third common errors, my
price hast to be less than my competitor’s
price. If they’re charging $5,000, the best way
to enter a market is to charge $4000. Why
– no one would pay any more than the existing
incumbents. And we’re going to see that’s
another going out of business strategy. And
all this depends on your knowledge that you’ve
just learned about the customers, their reaction
to the value proposition and all the work you’ve
been doing outside the building. You’re
going to have an incredible advantage
in thinking about revenue and pricing.